the news about the vaccine means the end
of the pandemic is in sight
but before we get there we have one big
hurdle
christmas will it happen and if it does
will it be dangerous hospital emissions
are the key measure for the success of
any lockdown
and right now as you can see they're
rising nationally
now that's to be expected because
they're on a lag but we have a long way
to fall from here
and it's still only two weeks till
december second
the good news is there's some sign of
leveling off in the northwest as you can
see
hospital emissions are flat even
reducing
but no covert news comes without bad
news
to lift locked down fully we need things
to come down from this high level
then there's no clear sign they're doing
that right now this data
matches up with the reports which
suggests we'll come out of lockdown
into a slightly lighter lockdown than
have christmas
as a bit of a free or break what will be
worrying ministers
is the idea that this break will turn
into a spike
and the signs on that are not promising
now take a look at this
this is retail and recreation movement
data from google
and you can see as soon as lockdown was
announced in england
everyone went out this spike here in
cambridge they went out
in hull in southampton they went out
right across the country
it's the same thing happens over
christmas and we could be in trouble
now you might say well this is an
innately human tendency when you're
looking at a deadline
but that's actually not the case look at
this
this is the same movement data for
glasgow
and it's pretty much completely flat
even
when restrictions were announced in
scotland and experts say
there's a big difference in the way the
communications are landing in scotland
and england certainly levels of public
trust and confidence in the devolved
governments is different
so scotland currently has the highest
confidence level with wales and england
has the lowest confidence level
and we know that who it is that is
delivering the message is important to
whether or not people are going to trust
in the message
believe in the message and then act on
the message
when they announced a november lockdown
they would have hoped
the outbreak was going to come down very
quickly it still could
but if it doesn't they will face very
tough choices
government scientists say that every one
day of easing
needs five days of tightening to
counteract it
so we could end up with five days of a
christmas break
resulting in 25 days of lockdown in
january
by any standard that if we don't get it
right
is a hell of a christmas hangover